there are three different types of
people when it comes down to writing
business plans one those who don't write
business plans two those who write
business plans in the month of December
but past February they never look at it
again and three those who write a
business plan with logic and emotion
that fires them up and they read it all
year long and they hit 80 percent of
their numbers on the business plan today
I'm going to talk to you about the 12
building blocks of writing a business
plan that produces logic and emotion at
the same time so stick around to the
very end to introduce you to our online
university that we have to learn how to
become a better speaker you know sales
person strategy a place that very few
people know about stick around I'll let
you know how to find the online
university and if you get value from
this video give us a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel so let's get
right into it
foreign
building blocks when I want to go into a
new year and I want to see what I need
to do to improve as a salesperson
employee CEO founder executive I Break
It Down based on 12 different building
blocks the first two I look at is Will
and skill now when you look at willpower
and skill set what do we talk about so
for example skill set I'll sit there and
say what skills do I need for 2023 do I
need to learn how to become a better
salesperson negotiator conflict
resolution how to bring people together
raising money understanding numbers
report balance sheet coding what do I
need to get better at skill set then I
go put a plan together on how I can get
better in those skill sets
simultaneously if I have a team of
people that work with me I'll write out
my Executives or my sales leaders and
I'll say when I talk to Johnny for his
annual review on December 18th what am I
going to give them feedback on areas he
needs to improve in it's a leadership is
it management is it accountability is it
character is it a heart skill was it a
soft skill what is it so I'll typically
have that in place on what I need to
improve skill set wise and what my
leaders around me need to improve skill
set advice as well as companies so
that's skill but that's not enough the
complete opposite of skill is willpower
I know a lot of great sales people I
know a lot of great negotiators I know a
lot of great coders I know a lot of
great people who have very very strong
heart skills but when it comes down to
deadline they miss the deadline when it
comes down to a lot of pressure they
don't will themselves into wrapping it
up when it comes down to getting
something done that everybody's
reluctant there's a lot of things going
on oh my God I don't know how we're
going to handle it you all of a sudden
see them breaking you know oh my God
they can't handle that part right that's
willpower you're going to have certain
people that maybe their skill set is low
but their willpower is hard it takes a
lot to break them you need to work on
this person's skill set but you got a
lot of people that you're gonna have
their skill set being here under
willpower being here it may be you it
may be someone on your team you have to
figure out a way how to increase your
willpower the way you increase your
willpower hour is by small victories you
say you're going to work out three times
a week you do it you say you're gonna go
get XYZ done you do it you say you're
gonna go read this book and write a
report on it by next Friday you do it
gradually your confidence in you goes up
and eventually you say whatever comes
out of my mouth is gonna get done
because my willpower is increasing so
first two building blocks are skill set
and will here's a quick shout out to our
sponsor fund and grow these guys
recently grabbed my attention because
it's small business built by helping
other small businesses Thrive I'm a big
fan of what they do they offer a
12-month business credit card stacking
membership that gives entrepreneurs and
small businesses an alternative to
traditional funding throughout their
membership funding girl maintains the
credit cards at zero percent interest so
that you can effortlessly manage your
day-to-day business expenses
Additionally you won't have to give up
Equity of your business anyone in almost
any industry can use business credit
unsecured business credit is one of the
most innovative ways to get startup
Capital without have having to weave
through lots of red tape with bangs if
you don't know the business we have an
idea and you want to start a business
that'll help you start a complimentary
LLC or a sole proprietorship that'll
save you money and the time of going
through a lawyer or an attorney there's
a webinar there CEO re page did that
will give you an Insight on how to make
your business lendable to banks credit
report secrets and how the banks are
trying to scam you by giving you the
smallest limits even when you deserve
more so go to fundandgirl.com forward
slash pbd watch the webinar and when you
sign up today you'll get 500 off their
12-month funding program which by the
way is tax write-off once again go to
fundandgrow.com forward slash pbd check
out the webinar save that 500 off your
membership they've helped over thirty
thousand businesses and they can help
you as well let's look at the next two
building blocks then you have plan and
Mission on the bottom again you notice
skill is logical plan is logical will is
emotional mission is emotional plan is
how do you write out a business plan to
sit there and say what are we going to
do q1 Q2 Q3 Q4 plan of what you know
demographic we're getting we're going to
get into what technology we need this
year who we need to go out there and
expand in what territories the business
plan is more of what we're going to be
doing on a daily basis weekly basis
monthly basis you know different kind of
incentives we're going to have all these
things that you're writing out your plan
for everything we need a plan right but
at the top is a mission if I would ask
you right now what's your mission
statement for your life what are you
going to be doing with your life what's
your mission could you say it if you and
I sat down right here we had a five
minute conversation and I said tell me
your mission in life what do you want to
do I'm not looking for a same sentence
that you've said a few thousand times
although for us when I started my own
insurance company I had a very simple
mission statement bringing back the free
enterprise system and hope to American
families I've said that phrase fifteen
thousand times twenty thousand times
that was our mission statement but I
have my own as well you yourself
obviously I run a uh I have a BPW course
business planning workshop where I get
into
full day on this course if you want to
find out more about it I'll put the link
below but you for your mission statement
you'll notice musk has a mission
statement personal not Tesla not Twitter
but musk Oprah Winfrey has a mission
statement not harpole but herself some
of the people that do the biggest things
in life they have a mission statement
that mission produces emotion it's not
how-to it's Y2 so again the second
building block is having the right
business plan being written and number
two getting clear on what your mission
is it'll produce an emotion and energy
that a logical business plan alone just
won't do so so far we got for the
business building blocks knocked out of
the way the next two you got systems you
got dream in systems I looked at every
single thing whether I'm running a media
company just I'll give you an idea
yesterday we did a webinar on wealth
generational wealth webinar right we
started 12 minutes late I wasn't happy
about it right afterwards we had a
debrief and I sat there and said guys
what happened here today everybody said
well it was this it was that it was this
here's a challenge that we had the
PowerPoint was done on a complete
different computer and the computer that
got transferred to PowerPoint all of a
sudden the words were choppy all over
the place I'm sure you've seen this
before when it happens right so he said
and then so cool let me try to get this
let's do this ship bring another Apple
let's do this computer 12 minutes later
we're late 12 minutes and there's 5 000
people that are waiting for us right at
the end when it ended I said guys I want
a system on what we need to do before we
do a live webinar so one guy said I need
the PowerPoint three days before the
webinar for us to test it out great
let's define what test is what is test
the final webinar in my hands design
great so when does the designer needed
to spruce up the Genera the whatever
webinar it is they need a three days
prior to that so that means the person
that's putting together webinar has to
have it approved by me a week prior to
that to hand it over to our designer for
the designer to put it together to give
it to our camera folks and the team
folks who say we're ready to go live
three days from now so anyways we're
putting a checklist together we need
systems to approve everything everything
is about systems the other night I'm
walking with a guy who's a father who's
got four kids his kids oldest kid is
seven years older than my oldest kid and
I noticed while we're doing Halloween
trick-or-treating we always talk and I
noticed one of his kids comes by and he
says hey um my son you know he's a
little upset right now why because he
lost his technology privileges away why
what is technology privileges he doesn't
have his phone he doesn't have his iPad
he doesn't why did he lose all that
stuff well because he doesn't have
straight A's in our family you want your
iPhone you want all that stuff you need
straight A's sat there thinking about
said can I apply that to my own family
that's their system to get their kids to
get straight A's that system is
transferable systems for business system
for recruiting system for hiring system
for script system for customer service
system for handling complaints
everything is about systems so what
areas of your business do you have leaks
in your system you got to take a look at
that but the complete opposite side of
system which is emotional is dreams what
are your dreams what do you want to do
today I'm doing a Consulting for this
one company they do three billion
dollars a year of funding in real estate
in Canada and we're having this
conversation about what they want to do
and the guy said what we're doing this
what we're doing that what we're doing
so tell me what your dream is what do
you want to do do you want to sell this
company you want to take it public do
you want to keep it and pass it down to
your family what do you want to do
what's your dream if you don't know your
dreams and it doesn't excite you
eventually you're just going to be doing
business as usual I'll give you a crazy
story about myself I'm 27 years old my
goal was to have a quarter million
dollars in savings so all of a sudden I
got a quarter million dollars in the
bank at 28 and I'm driving a nice car
I've traveled the world my dad's happy
he's no longer working at a 99 cent
store all of my dreams have become a
paid off my credit card then my credit
score is at 800 but I didn't replace
those dreams that I had with new ones
you know what happened the next six
months I was all over the place I was
bored I didn't know what I'm running for
and then quickly time my way over time
what are your next three four five six
seven eight dreams I wrote out a
business plan I'll never forget fired me
up you know what's crazy when I wrote
out the business plan
right off the bat my girlfriend and I
start dating she becomes my wife a year
and a half later then you got family
kids company all this other things that
happened because I got clear about my
dreams my dreams your dreams then you
have to sit there and with your
executive team and leadership team
asking them what are your dreams so it's
not just important for you to know your
dreams is whatever your leadership team
is knowing their dreams and challenging
them to have conversations with their
employees about what their dreams are
now what's a conversation when what if
somebody's making 15 bucks an hour what
are you talking to them about dreams
it's not Ferraris and Lamborghinis but
what do you tell them hey I'd like the
one to be a manager here fantastic I'd
like to one to be able to buy my own
house five years from now condo great
people have dreams so on the bottom with
systems top is dream so far we have six
billion blocks the next two Capital
Vision Capital Money one of the guys I
was talking to upstairs right before
this meeting this guy said I got a
million dollars on a bank well my run
break with the company is 250 which
means I got four weeks he says I got six
hundred thousand dollars a line of
credit for the company and I got five
hundred thousand dollars in my savings
right now what do I do should I go buy a
house and I said well you ain't got a
lot of capital if you think about how
much of your expenses you got set aside
it ain't that long because you're doing
quarter a week so that's a good point
pump the brakes so we got a capital
issue here let's get the capital a
little bit bigger before we do x y z or
we got to go raise money for you it may
be I got thirty thousand dollars in the
bank that's your Capital what do I do
with this thirty thousand dollars how do
you increase it what is your Capital
goal what do you need to be should you
go buy something that's a card that's
900 bucks a month well you only have
thirty thousand dollars in a bank maybe
you go get a 450 car or a used car right
that's the capital conversation you're
having do you go hire five employees or
do you hire one employee based on the
capital that's you go raise the capital
the opposite of capital is Vision do you
know what the vision is where are we
going what are we doing what are we
going to be three years from now five
years from now what is the long-term
vision of the company that you're
running your business can you recite
your vision to your wife to your husband
to your kids to your co-workers to your
employees to your customers do you know
your vision where you're going sometimes
people can have tens of millions of
dollars in their Bank some even billions
call FTX but if there's no real vision
and it's all fake eventually you're not
only going to hurt the people around you
but you're eventually going to get
distracted and hurt yourself you need a
real Clear Vision that fires you up and
the people around you so capital is good
but Vision brings energy it's emotional
next to competition versus enemy a lot
of times everybody talks about go study
your competition if you're on real
estate what is your competition to well
these guys do this and Keller Williams
does this and experience these guys do
that and done all these guys do that
great you can get as much competition as
you want you need to study at the
marketplace who's coming out with one
product what demos are they in What
markets are they in what technology are
they using what's going on with the
differentiation that this company has
from those guys from these guys how do
they get their customers how do those
guys get their customers why do they
sell Compass sales to higher and
Providence versus Keller Williams has
this over here should I go lower and
Middle Market should I go higher Market
what is it that's competition studying
the competition you got to do that and
that requires the ability to know how to
research researching is a very very high
paid skill set to know how to research
but the complete opposite of competition
is enemy enemy is a different story an
enemy wakes you up in a morning without
an alarm clock and any knee allows you
to stay up in your office or your
kitchen at night while everybody else is
asleep you're doing research to find out
how to grow even faster than you are
today because an enemy has produced a
certain energy in you a lot of people
say Pat what are you talking about with
enemy I am 29 30 years old about to
start an insurance company this is the
first time where I'm experiencing what
it is to when you start a company and
all of a sudden you experience violently
opposed first you're ridiculed then
you're violently opposed and it's
self-evident right well before you
become self-evident where everybody in
the marketplace says look I don't care
what you say about Pat you got to
respect them look I don't care what they
say about you you got to respect them
that same status takes a long time to
earn right the phase before faint status
is being violently opposed and even
prior to violently opposed is ridiculed
what's ridicule look at these guys
they're idiots they think they're going
to figure this out look at John he
doesn't know what he's doing you think
that guy's going to do something in real
estate ridiculed they're making fun of
you but they don't believe you can do
what you're doing violently opposed is
when you're officially taking
Marketplace then they start attacking
you reviews defamation of character
manipulation games infighting pinning
people in your company against you
that's when the enemy me starts doing
that and I said no problem you want to
do that to me a competitor did that to
me I said great it's officially no
longer competition it's war two years
there was only one audiobook playing in
my car for two straight years you know
what it was 33 Strategies of War by
Robert Greene a good friend of mine and
I listened to it every day
365 days per year on repeat to know I'm
not gonna let the big bullies bully me
this is why one of the values in our
family were my kids when I say four
things we do lead respect improve life
but we don't bully but we definitely
don't get bullied and when a bully tries
to bully you best stand up in a
Marketplace that's going to happen that
enemy produced an energy in me now enemy
for you may be a father who's no longer
in your life like Tyler Perry who said
my dad wasn't in a picture when I was
coming up when I needed you weren't
there later on when I'm rich Hector
million are about to be a billionaire
and now you want to show up no problem
guess what I'm going to do to you I'm
going to buy you a car and pay it off
I'm going to buy you a house and pay it
off I'm going to give you some money but
with only one caveat what's that never
call me ever again I want you to
experience what you did to me when I
needed you as a kid and you weren't
there I love you you will forever be my
father but here you go you think the
drive that he has is just because he
wants to make movies and that's it or do
you think there's something deeper than
that you think jobs being given up to
adoption was just about the whole basic
stuff of hey I want to go out there and
build Apple into multi-multi trillion
dollar company you know when he was a
kid it was given up for adoption you
don't think he wants to say how dare you
adopt me I'm a I'm a great kid you
should have never given me up for
adoption there are different kinds of
enemies enemy's not about a war you're
going to go to fight them but it
produces energy we know Brady is all
about enemy we know Jordan's all about
enemy we know a lot of people in
business are all about enemy politics
military the list goes on you need an
enemy to produce that energy for you and
last but not least Supporting Cast and
culture Supporting Cast at the bottom is
who you have around you who do I need to
recruit next whose Health do I need an
assistant processor business person
advisor board member it doesn't matter
you need to write down to your
Supporting Cast on who you need it may
be as basic as an assistant someone most
basic thing that sometimes entrepreneurs
don't want to get the assistant to do to
do the work for them and you're doing a
bunch of 15 20 30 an hour work an
assistant can help you out with that all
you need to do is go get an assistant so
that's Supporting Cast but the emotional
side of it is what culture to people at
your office kind of leave exactly at 459
because they can't wait to leave and go
home and watch sports or Netflix or
something else or maybe your culture
meets some issues need some help because
it's not where it needs to be or is your
culture the kind of place you're like
guys go home no one wants to go home
they're having a ton of fun they're
coming in they're having a blast They're
laughing there's potlucks there's gift
exchange there is joking there is humor
there's competition there's
entertainment people are getting their
job done it's competitive your culture
may need to have some kind of facelift
to get better what is that area with
your culture maybe you got to look at
some cultures that have done world
company-wise and apply to your business
again I can talk about this all day this
is why I host a event once you're called
business planning workshop and we talk
about this portfolio where people from
100 plus countries come together and we
talk about how to put a business plan
together but I'm giving you the shorter
version of the 12 building blocks I'm
writing a book right now with penguin
portfolio specifically on how to write a
business plan that will not be
introduced until a year and a half from
the coming out but these are the 12
building blocks now a couple different
things
one I have an online Academy okay where
I have multiple courses public speaking
persuasion communication Sales Systems
that I use my 10 power closes or
strategy how to recruit how to fire how
to raise money all of that stuff that I
have it's on an online university for
valuetainment with David Consulting if
you want to learn more about that click
over here and on the other side I did a
video I think six years ago titled how
to write a one-page business plan if
you've never seen it click here to watch
that video and if you got value out of
it give it a thumbs up and subscribe to
the channel take care everybody
foreign